sa carrière en annoncer quand même un
petit peu rapide arrivée à être
françoise hardy woods alors vous trouvez
pas moi je trouve que c'est mais c'est
râpé c'est même trop rapide parce que
c'est pas un an qu'on peut arriver à
apprendre le métier être qu'avant
voyez il ya deux ans je chantais pas du
tout et beaucoup de
deux chanteurs d'artistes qui avant que
ça marche je travaille beaucoup sur le
plan je fonde avec apparaît toujours
comme ça dit que moi je
l'usure
m
pas de soleil
qui
jour houleux sur terre
et
keisse
des sons
eva nouvel avis vous êtes tout seul là
sur votre petit banc mais expliquez moi
pourquoi vous n'êtes ni avec ses
camarades ni avec ses camarades là est
ce que vous êtes contrôlés ou pour le
romantisme ou mon frère je suis entre
les deux justement sur la rue du moment
vous avez entre les deux oui qu'est ce
que ça veut dire avoir je pense que je
fais des chansons dont les paroles sont
doux mais il dans l'air est quand même
un petit peu avant 8 chacun du jeu
qui se pose est prononcée qu'après
souvent rêver au prince charmant
concessions s'est passé en france 12h17
mélancolie dans vos yeux et dans vos
chansons
c'est sans doute l'expression de votre
âge de votre tempérament
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est aussi
l'expression chanter d'une époque où
tout au moins d'une génération
moi je pense toujours que les gens de ma
génération on veut y aura toutes les
époques des moments de cafard et une
joie et puis quand on aime les retrouver
dans les chansons tournez-vous il ya
quelque chose qui m'intrigue avez mis
votre chandail à l'envers express vers
est trop grand mais c'est une idée de
mode saas est jolie